the deadly flooding in germany has
overshadowed chancellor angela merkel's
farewell visit to the united states
she'll leave office in september after
years as one of europe's key political
figures
talks with president biden focused on
climate change and
an enduring disagreement over a russian
gas pipeline
unlike his predecessor president joe
biden treated mackel as a friend rather
than foe for her day at the white house
it's been a long time since the german
chancellor received a welcome this
warm in washington chancellor merkel
back into the white house where she's
been in the oval office many times she's
been a great friend
i consider a personal friend as well as
a great friend of the united states
and uh after the tense diplomatic
relationship with former president trump
both president joe biden and chancellor
angela merkel
stressed the friendship between their
two countries
we will stand up for democratic
principles and universal rights
when we see china or any other country
working to undermine
free and open societies we stand
together
and we'll continue to stand together to
defend our eastern flank
allies at nato against russian
aggression
but germany and the u.s do not agree on
how to deal with
either russia or china the planned
gigantic nordstream 2 pipeline will
bring russian natural gas into europe
washington says the project makes the
continent more dependent on russia
and threatens the security of its
smaller neighbors like ukraine
merkel has long championed the project
but played down the differences
we talked about russia and ukraine and
in this context
also about nordstrom 2 we've come to
different assessments as to what this
project entails
but let me say clearly our idea is and
remains that ukraine remains a transit
country for natural gas
and that ukraine like any other country
has a right to territorial sovereignty
the chancellor's farewell tour of
washington began with a breakfast with
vice president kamala harris
and later the johns hopkins university
bestowed an honorary degree on the
former physicist
merkel's time as german chancellor may
be drawing to a close
but she has left a lasting impression on
the us
but president a personal note i must
tell you i'll miss seeing you at our
summits
i truly will with the biden presidency
u.s german relations are calmer but big
differences remain
dw reporter william bluecroft is
following the chancellor's visit to the
states for us hi william
we heard in that report that differences
do remain so tell us more about
how those differences were discussed in
these talks
good morning sumi there's so many
differences in this relationship that
have no
clear strategy for resolving as much as
they say they want to resolve them and
want to remain on a friendly agreeable
path you have you know china for example
the us sees it
as a not just an economic threat but
also a strategic and military one
germany and europe more broadly has
basically sees it only as an economic
opportunity
you have european and common security
and germany's role
they're in what it's ready to commit in
terms of security and military and
defense
uh of course covet travel americans can
travel to
the european union but germans and other
europeans can't travel to the u.s there
is no
clear resolution of that and of course
the vaccine patent question
germany wants to go with the kovacs the
kovacs route to get vaccines
into lower income countries and biden
already months ago
said he's prepared to waive patent
waivers or excuse me wave patents
uh to allow other countries to develop
them so there's just so many things that
just didn't really come out in any
substantive way in this meeting
yesterday
we saw one of the largest disagreements
is still the nordstrom 2 pipeline
and we saw president biden and
chancellor merkel issue a warning to
russia to not use
energy as a weapon but william do they
have a strategy there if russia does
choose to limit gas supplies
to europe right it's a great example
of just how there may be goals and
there's ideas and there's general
agreement but there's just no strategy
or policy in place for how to actually
achieve those things
we know that the united states that joe
biden and many european allies
are absolutely against nordstream 2
given its strategic
challenges to europe energy security
climate concerns
germany is pushing forward with it after
a very tense winter and spring where
there is
threat and in fact some sanctions
imposed biden has backed off
saying really it's too late to do
anything about it but the u.s congress
says
no oh this these sanctions are not
optional they are
law and they are pushing biden to
actually impose those sanctions
um and so really remains to be seen how
that's going to be worked out but we
knew going into this meeting uh in
a background call with a senior white
house official he said
already there would be no concrete
deliverable on the nordstream 2 issue so
we knew going in that nothing was really
going to come out of this in a concrete
way
and william given these disagreements
after september's elections there will
be a new german chancellor
how much could that actually change the
u.s german relationship
it's extremely interesting what's going
to happen come september and after when
there's going to be a new government in
place
you know of course we don't know who's
going to be in that government polls are
looking like it will either be or could
be
the greens or angela merkel's
conservative
the union uh coalition or some
combination of that
and each party based on their platform
kind of aligns with joe biden's thoughts
and agenda
in different ways the greens more
aligned with biden's ideas about climate
about human rights democracy approaching
or confronting russia and china
and and the conservatives are more
aligned in more traditional
uh aspects of nato of common defense uh
of military spending these kinds of
things but really germany has a long
history of not really stepping up to the
plate to meet its global
responsibilities as a major power
and has disappointed the united states
and many many times in many ways
and that could be the result regardless
of the party uh that wins or the
coalition that comes together after
september's elections
william gluecroft reporting for us there
thank you
german chancellor angela merkel and u.s
president joe biden maintained their
disagreement
over the contentious nordstrom 2
pipeline during a visit by angela merkel
to the white house on thursday
both however stressed the need for
ukraine to remain a transit land for
russian gas
the u.s wants germany to scrap the deal
altogether with russia
and has put sanctions on the project
germany has defended it as
economically necessary
let's take a listen to what the german
chancellor had to say
we have talked about china and there is
a great common understanding that
firstly china is a competitor in many
areas
that trade with china has to be based on
us having a level playing field
that means that the standards are the
same incidentally this was a major point
of negotiation in the eu
china investment agreement and andrew
adair from the german engineering
association vdma joins us now
thank you very much for joining us
andrew and it's kind of hard to
to draw conclusions from this meeting it
seems to simply be
a holding pattern and a whole bunch of
subjects nordstrom china and so on
is biden just biding his time until
merkel's successor comes along
hey good morning thanks for having me um
yes in some ways that's true uh although
i'd i'd like to
first start out by uh sharing with you
the perspective of vdma
which is we are extremely delighted that
there is
a sign of of progress in the
travel ban the travel ban right now
which has been in effect since march of
2020
prevents travelers from the schengen
area from coming into the united states
without a
waiver which they have to apply for it's
a very burdensome process
and last night uh joe biden indicated
that there could be
um there was a review of this
travel ban going on and that there could
be an announcement in the coming days
based on the uh action of his kovid team
so we are
the the lifting of this travel ban is
not going to make that much difference
at the moment we're still in the
pandemic
we're about to talk about lufthansa
later and you know we're seeing that
business travel
is still extremely low even within
europe is this going to make much of a
difference
yes for for vdma for our member
companies
lifting the travel ban will make a huge
difference and it will also make a huge
difference
for our american clients who
at the end of the day need their
machines and their equipment maintained
they need their equipment installed
these things
they can't order you know packaging
machines out of a box from amazon you
need to have
a technician fly over and install it
they're extremely complicated complex
technologies every few months these
things need to optimize so there are
many examples of production processes in
the united states that have been put on
hold
or that have been stopped altogether
because of specific
technicians that have not been able to
enter the united states
okay so it seems that at least we're
getting some movement there
but back to to nordstream where we're
still not seeing any agreement
it seems to have just been kicked into
the long grass is there any way
forward on this because both sides just
seem to be at opposite opposite ends
still
yes i mean at vdma our position
is um that extra territorial sanctions
are not a good way to conduct business
and so
that is out that remains our position
going forward
okay all right thank you very much
andrew adair from the vdma thanks very
much
thank you
you